منذ ثلاثه اشهر غيرت اتصال من طبيب حياه
محمد الذي اخبره بتوفر قرنيه من متبرع
محمد حمدان فقد عينه اليسرى بعد اصابته
بالحمى الشوكيه باقي اسمه على لائحه
الانتظار للزراعه في وزاره الصحه منذ عام
يعني عضو بده بده حدا يمسكه بده حدا
يقولوا صار هو عضو فعال في المجتمع
تعتبر عمليه زراعه القرنيه التي اجريت
للشعب محمد حمدان الاولى منذ عام 2013
عقبه حمله التبرع بالاعضاء التي اطلقت من
قبل وزاره الصحه في اغسطس ابي الماضي
الاستجابه الايجابيه للحمله ونجاح
العمليات التي اجريت في مستشفيات القطاع
اعطى الامل للكثيرين وتم اجراء قرابه 25
عمليه لزراعه القرنيه من بين 500 حاله
مسجله في قوائم الانتظار
بنكرانيات نستطيع بعد ذلك يعني عندما يكون
لدينا رصيد انه يعني انه جدول العمليات
التي تنتظر على
دورها في همم العمليه وبذلك ابناء شعبنا
في هذا الشعب المحاصر في غزه يعني همم
مشاكل السفر واعباء وتكاليفه
ومعقده من جان تكلفه النقل العاليه وطول
الطريق بسبب طبيعه المعابر الواصله لقطاع
غزه حيث تتعرض الاعضاء للتلف بسبب ظروف
النقل